[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
according to the World Health
Organization 16 percent of all deaths
worldwide are from cancer about 9
million per year the annual cost on the
healthcare system is about one trillion
dollars chances are you've probably
known someone who's had cancer well
today there's good news there's been
some rapid progress in the battle
against cancer it comes in the form of a
new treatment for aggressive types of
cancer that can't be cured with chemo or
radiation therapy trained to kill right
now there's a new cancer treatment the
doctors say really works and we're
already seeing success stories here in
San Diego
yeah 10 News reporter Jessica Chen is in
the newsroom with the treatment that
trained cells to find and destroy cancer
Jessica yeah that's right Anna and
Arielle I met a guy his name was Robert
and his cancer it will it just kept
coming back but he underwent this new
treatment called car T cell therapy and
within weeks he's cancer-free now here's
a picture of what it kind of looks like
now this red it's a red T cell it's
trained to kill and here it is attaching
itself to the white that's the cancer
eventually killing it
the success rate has been above 83
percent in some trials and the best part
is it's just been approved by the FDA in
the United States and has been trialed
in selected hospitals around the world
in this video we'll take a look the new
treatment is called chimeric antigen
receptor t cell therapy or car T for
short in basic terms the therapy uses
the patient's own blood to create a kind
of living medicine after just one dose
the medicine will work for an extended
period of time
to seek out and destroy cancer it sounds
far-fetched but I'll explain how it
works in more detail later on in the
video
the breakthrough here is as follows
normally the immune system fails to
recognize cancer and some studies
suggest that the immune system even
mistakenly protects cancer cells through
genetic engineering Carty treatment
causes the body to recognize and
to the patient's specific case of cancer
car t-cell therapy I think is quite
likely to change the landscape for
treatment of patients with blood cancer
it involves a genetic modification of a
patient's immune system such that the
white blood cells a specific white blood
so called the T lymphocyte is modified
in such a way to attack and destroy
cancer cells it's very exciting so
basically it's extracted from the
patient modified and then reinjected so
your body can fight with its own body
I guess that's exactly right wow that's
that's incredible
using the body's own immune system to
fight cancer is called immunotherapy and
cartee is the most promising form of
this approach the reason people are so
excited about this is because it
produced incredible results and patients
where all other treatments fail to work
right now the treatment has been
approved for children with the most
aggressive forms of leukemia a cancer
that spreads through the blood but other
approvals are closed in the pipeline at
first I was skeptical but the more I
researched into it the more miraculous
cases I found of the treatment working
we've checked her bone marrow for the
possibility of disease I had two points
we checked her three months and now six
months out from her treatment she has no
disease whatsoever seems like the cells
stick around for a long time that
actually might provide long term disease
control that is of course the most
exciting potential part Scott was one of
the first people to receive car t-cell
therapy as a trial he was at a point in
his fight with cancer where he had no
other options but Carty gave him a
chance Michael Bishop is one of the
doctors who provided care to Scott to
say them excited would be a major
understatement next scan will behold
cancer-free
John remission so I've been remission
now for about 15 months every month it
gets better and better my strength has
come back
stan was come back basically I'm back
living a full life again enjoying things
I like to enjoy so it just absolutely
been a miracle and I old so much to the
team at University of Chicago so how
does it work exactly as mentioned
earlier the treatment is a custom living
drug taken from the patient's blood and
fights cancer within the patient for
extended periods of time the treatment
begins by extracting something called
t-cells from the patient's blood t-cells
are a type of white blood cells that are
integral to the immune system they're
naturally built to seek out and attack
infections in the body next these
t-cells are mixed with a disarmed virus
that's engineered to produce a special
kind of receptor on its surface these
receptors are synthetic molecules that
don't exist naturally these newly
engineered receptors allow the t-cells
to find recognize and destroy cancer
cells they do this by attaching the
artificially engineered receptors onto
the surface of the cancer cells
injecting them with poison and
destroying it the scientists then grow
millions of clients of these new t-cells
in the lab the engineered t-cells then
multiply and live within the body
providing long-term relief because these
cells multiply you never have to go in
again for a top-up dose think of it as a
one-time treatment of a personalized
medicine I would ask you about that
clinical trial a lot of questions people
have around the durability of their
responses how long are people actually
staying with their cancer in check what
have you been seeing and what do you
expect to see as the results mature what
we can infer is for patients with it
that were treated in early smaller
studies at the NIH some of the patients
are now approaching five years these are
patients that had no evidence of any
cancer them now while in the past they
have failed every possible therapy the
treatment has been tested extensively on
both children and adults suffering
leukemia with unprecedented rates of
success this includes stubborn cases of
reoccurring cancer that failed to
respond to traditional treatments
in one study all signs of cancer
disappeared in 27 out of 30 participants
that's a 90% success rate in another
more recent study there was an overall
remission rate of 83% within 3 months
for a trial of 63 patients Carty cells
have produced strong results not only in
patients with leukemia but also patients
with lymphoma a cancer of the lymph
glands
for example James cotton derf our
medical doctor of the National Cancer
Institute states quote our data is the
first true glimpse of the potential of
this approach in patients with
aggressive lymphomas who until this
point were virtually untreatable end
quote
in other words this treatment cured
patients that would otherwise have most
likely died dr. Steven Rosenberg chief
of the surgery branch ulcer at the
National Cancer Institute mentions that
in just the last few years progress of
car t-cells and similar approaches have
greatly accelerated quote in the next
few years I think we're going to see
dramatic progress and push the
boundaries of what many people thought
was possible with these adoptive cell
transfer based treatments end quote
dr. Brent Jones of the Memorial Sloan
Kettering Cancer Center was skeptical
and initially thought that this
treatment would be a boutique therapy
limited to a small defined patient group
but what he's seen over the past years
has made him change his mind
quote we have cohorts of patients who
have been considered terminal and are
now in durable and meaningful remissions
with good quality of life for up to five
years so enthusiasm for this technology
is now quite high end quote so is this
all too good to be true
well not quiet but there are a couple of
major downsides
the first one there's a serious and
potentially fatal side-effect swelling
of the brain known as cerebral edema
this is serious and hasn't fortunately
led to some deaths
however the problem seems to be
extremely limited and many of the other
Carty cell therapies have reported no
such instances of the complication
now the second downside is probably the
most heartbreaking part it's the price
Novartis one of the first companies to
have the commercial version of the
treatment available is charging four
hundred seventy-five thousand dollars
for the one-time treatment although
they're promising not to charge patients
who don't respond within a month some
experts in the field say that the price
will come down as the manufacturing
process becomes standardized and argue
that even at this price it may not even
be profitable for the company but still
this is a point of contention for me but
regardless the research on car t-cells
is continuing at a swift pace mostly in
patients with blood cancers but also in
patients with solid tumors the number of
clinical trials testing car t-cells has
expanded dramatically from just a
handful a number of years ago to over a
hundred and Counting doctors are turning
their attention to solid cancer tumors
with talk of a super t-cell earlier the
see our doctors have now reported
success in prostate cancer
the Carty treatment is the first ever
cell based gene therapy now publicly
available in the United States and the
FDA calls its decision a historic action
and I could agree
unlike previous claims of revolutionary
cancer treatments this does look like
it's going to be something truly
historic
so in conclusion although it's in its
early stages and is quite expensive I
see this as a beacon of hope in the
fight against cancer the numbers and the
success rate are hard to argue it so
that's really it I realized that this
story isn't widely known to the general
public so I really wanted to shine a
light on it and get people talking about
it so what do you guys think let me know
your thoughts in the comment section
below so anyway thanks for watching this
has been - go go you've been watching
cold fusion feel free to subscribe if
you've just stumbled across this channel
and I'll see you soon again for the next
video cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
taking
[Music]
[Music]
you